bien supongamos que estoy en r2 que
estoy en el plano y que tengo el vector
tengo el vector 1 2
este vector se ve más o menos así
vamos que esto es uno
el vector más o menos se ve algo así
andrás ok ahora si me fijo en el
conjunto de múltiplos reales de este
vector es decir me fijo en el conjunto l
de múltiplos de este vector de vectores
de la forma t por el vector 12 donde
donde te
un real el número real lo que obtengo es
una línea recta
el conjunto l es la línea generada por
este vector por el vector 12 que se ve
más o menos así la línea está un poco
seca pero
pero bueno más o menos algo así se ve la
línea el
ahora supongamos que tengo un vector
aquí
supongamos que tengo este vector x
el vector x voy a definir una
transformación de r 2 en r 2 y la
transformación la voy a definir como
reflexión reflexión con respecto a esta
recta l entonces tengo el vector x lo
mandó a su vector simétrico con respecto
a la línea más o menos mi idea es
una perpendicular e irme la misma
instancia del otro lado de la línea
ese punto me va a definir al vector de
la transformación tengamos este de aquí
sería t tx
recuerden te estoy tratando de definirla
como la transformación que es la
reflexión con respecto a la línea l
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo vamos a hacer
otro vector digamos digamos que tengo un
vector b 1
tarde 1 y lo voy a tomar ortogonal a la
línea perpendicular esta línea en
particular perpendicular al vector 12 si
quiere obtener un vector que sea parte
que sea perpendicular al 12 un vector
que sea perpendicular al 12
lo que hago es sencillamente los
intercambio y hago uno de ellos negativo
por ejemplo puedo tomarme el doctor 2 -
2 - 1 es un vector que es perpendicular
al vector 1 2 si hacen el producto punto
o el producto interior lo que les da hay
2 x 1 que es dos más dos x menos uno que
es menos 22 menos 20 así que estos dos
vectores son completamente
perpendiculares de hecho se ve más o
menos a 100 en la gráfica si gráfico el
doctor ve uno
se ve algo así
algo así aquí si se puede ver que es
ortogonal a esta línea el y a donde lo
manda la transformación pues la
transformación desde 1
es simplemente reflejarlo con respecto a
la línea l como el vector de uno es
perpendicular esta recta se refleja
simplemente pasando el otro lado que
yendo en sentido contrario
digamos
algo así su transformación
este sería la transformación de uno
y bueno no sé quién sea la matriz que
representa esta transformación respecto
a la base estándar pero sí puedo decir
que la transformación debe uno al menos
en este caso
es el vector
doctor que simplemente es ponerle un
menos a esto es menos 2
positivo
así actúa la transformación así que bien
vamos a formalizar un poco todo esto
estoy tratando de definir una
transformación de qué va de r2 a r2
de modo que te vx la transformación
aplicado un vector x es igual
la reflexión de x
la reflexión
x
con respecto
efecto
la línea del d
donde él pues ya sabemos es la recta
generada por el vector 12
ahora como estoy trabajando en
coordenada estándar yo sé yo sé que
existe una matriz de
pero existe una matriz yo sé que existe
una matriz y tal que la transformación
aplicado un vector x es lo mismo que
multiplicar a la matriz a por el vector
x esto siempre existe en
transformaciones lineales de hecho ya
hemos visto varios ejemplos de esto así
que como tengo a pues en general
es igual a la matriz cuyas columnas son
tómate el primer vector de la base
estándar de r 2 el vector 10 y aplicar
la transformación y el resultado va a
ser tu primera columna
para la segunda columna tómate la
transformación y aplicarla al segundo
vector de la base estándar tr2 el 01 y
esa va a ser tu segunda columna
así que la matriz a es una matriz de 2
por 2 cuyas columnas son precisamente
estos vectores ahora bien como pueden
encontrar estos vectores como por
encontrarte de 1 0 y 3 0 1 pues en
teoría podría hacer operaciones
trigonométricas y saber a dónde va a dar
por ejemplo el vector 10 que sería este
de aquí pero esto sería muy complicado
tendría que sacar muchos senos y cosenos
para determinar a dónde se va porque no
tengo que esta recta no es exactamente
la recta identidad no es la recta que
está a 45 grados así que esto en general
es más complicado
esto es complicado digamos esto no es
sencillo no es sencillo
así que debe haber otro modo debe haber
otro modo o nos gustaría que hubiera
otro modo de hacer esto de manera que
sea más fácil encontrar la matriz a sin
tener que encontrar directamente cuánto
vale la transformación en el vector 10 y
en el vector 01 bien pues hagamos un
breve repaso de lo que hemos visto hasta
ahora de lo que sabemos después de
algunos vídeos anteriores si tengo el
vector x en coordenadas estándar y lo
multiplicó por la matriz a entonces lo
que obtengo es la transformación
aplicada al vector x la imagen de x bajo
la transformación eso simplemente es
esta fórmula de aquí ahora bien yo sé
que r2 yo sé que r2 posee múltiples
bases y para cada base tengo un sistema
ordenado así que para una base b yo
podría escribir a x en coordenadas
respecto a esa base vamos x en
coordenadas respecto a la base d
y yo también sé que puedo pasar de las
coordenadas estándar a las coordenadas
respecto a la base ve multiplicando por
la inversa de la matriz de cambio base
la matriz de cambio va a ser les
recuerdo que simplemente es la matriz
cuyas columnas son precisamente los
vectores que conforman mi base ahora si
tengo el vector expresado en coordenadas
con respecto a la base b yo sé que
existe una matriz sé que existe una
matriz d
tal que de multiplicada por el vector de
coordenadas del vector x respecto a la
base b me da las coordenadas respecto a
la base b d tx
llegar las coordenadas respecto a la
base de la imagen bajo la transformación
de x
ahora de nuevo yo aquí podría pasar las
coordenadas estándar de las coordenadas
respecto a la base b multiplicando por
la inversa de la matriz de cambio base
todo podría pasar de las coordenadas
respecto a la base ve a las coordenadas
estándar multiplicando por la matriz de
cambio base así que aquí puedo traducir
estas cosas y en alguno de los vídeos
anteriores en alguno de los vídeos
anteriores vimos que la matriz d
vimos que la matriz d
tenía la forma sea la menos 1
porsche
y también vimos que era posible despejar
de aquí a la motriz
de esta ecuación obteníamos que a
tiene que ser de la forma
por d por sea la menos 1 así que si
encuentro en la matriz de para alguna
base se encuentra la matriz de la
transformación t respecto a alguna base
b puedo a partir de la matriz de cambio
base obtener la matriz a y quizás este
problema sea más sencillo para encontrar
la matriz a una vez que tengo la matriz
de simplemente utilizó esta fórmula de
aquí
ahora bien el problema es encontrar la
base adecuada de hecho en uno de los
vídeos pasados cité a un maestro de
álgebra que le dijo de sus alumnos que
el álgebra lineal era el arte de
encontrar la base adecuada así que cuál
es la base adecuada en este caso pues
primero que nada observemos que si la
línea él fuera el eje vertical entonces
reflejar sería muy sencillo si tengo
este vector para reflejarlo a través del
eje vertical o con respecto al eje
vertical simplemente intercambio su
primera coordenada por su negativo y eso
me da el reflejo así que una buena idea
sería tratar de hacer que el vector 12
jugará el papel del vector 0 1
también podemos notar que el vector b1
se transforma muy fácilmente si refleja
el vector b 1 con respecto a la línea l
entonces lo que obtengo es simplemente
menos de 1
tengo el signo contrario y además tiene
la ventaja de que es perpendicular a la
línea l así que voy a empezar a trabajar
con la base formada con la base de r2
formada por los vectores
2 - 1
recordemos el llamado de uno
y como segundo vector de mi base voy a
poner al 1 2
y esto va a ser director de 2
ok entonces
para encontrar la matriz de la
transformación respecto a la base de la
matriz de lo que tengo que hacer primero
es tratar de encontrar las coordenadas
respecto a la base de mis vectores de 1
y b 2
es decir
cuanto vale las coordenadas de v 1
dv 1 respecto a la base ve pues puedo
para empezar notar que ve 1
puedo empezar por notar el factor b 1 se
puede escribir como la combinación
lineal
uno por uno
+ 0 x b 2 ahora si recuerdan la
definición de coordenadas respecto a una
base es simplemente los coeficientes de
esta combinación lineal así que las
coordenadas del vector de 1 en la base b
y que el bebé 2
cuáles son las coordenadas de b2
respecto a la base b
pues de nuevo yo creo que ustedes ya
saben cuál va a ser la respuesta de dos
se puede escribir como la combinación
lineal 0 por b 1 más 1 por de 2
aquí el orden de la base es muy
importante
entonces las coordenadas respecto a la
base del vector b 2 son
0 1 justo como queríamos
0 1 muy bien de hecho en general
les hago aquí a una especie de
comentario en general
general
tengo
que deprima es una base de rn prima que
son estoy usando 6 supongamos que es la
base veo de prima es los vectores b1 b2
hasta
bn
y que esto es una base de rm
es una base
crm
entonces
entonces las coordenadas de cada beca
respecto a la base de prima
van a ser iguales
a un vector de la forma 0 0
o de repente 11 y luego puros ceros de
nuevo
así
la vuestro doctor
donde el uno aparece precisamente en la
k décima coordenada décima entrada
perdón
encima
entrada
ahora bien como encuentro la matriz de
pues si primero observamos que la matriz
de como es una transformación estamos
hablando de una transformación que va de
r2 en r2 entonces la matriz d
matriz de tiene que tener dos columnas y
de hecho dos filas también es una matriz
de dos por dos así que la podemos
representar por de uno de dos sus
columnas son de 1 y de 2
ahora qué pasa si multiplicó la matriz d
así que con la matriz de por el vector
de uno en coordenadas respecto a la base
b
pues esto por un lado es la matriz de
uno de dos
multiplicada por el vector
y eso es simplemente la combinación
lineal 1 por de 1
0 x de 2
o sea que está la de 1 el vector de 1
pero por el otro lado la matriz de tiene
la propiedad de que si la multiplicó por
un vector de coordenadas respecto a la
base b entonces me da las coordenadas
respecto a la base b de la imagen de ese
vector bajo la transformación así que
esto tiene que ser igual a
la transformación aplicada b1 expresada
y las coordenadas respecto a la base be
expresada con coordenadas respecto a la
base b
esto es simplemente esta condición que
tengo aquí abajo es lo que hace la
matriz de así que de uno tiene que ser
igual a las coordenadas en la base ve de
la imagen de bv
y qué hay de dos pues si ahora hago d
por dedos
depor b 2 en coordenadas respecto a la
base ve de nuevo esto sería lo mismo que
la matriz de uno de dos
pero ahora multiplicada por el doctor 01
y esto me da
0 x de 1
por dedos
que sencillamente es de 2
bien pero por el otro lado quien esté
por el vector de coordenadas de veedor
respecto a la base ve pues de nuevo de
acuerdo con esto esto tiene que ser lo
mismo que las coordenadas
respecto a la base ve
de el vector de la imagen del vector b 2
bajo la transformación
bien pues estos son buenas noticias
porque lo que quiere decir es que como
la matriz de desigualdad de uno de dos
ahora nosotros sabemos que de uno es
simplemente las coordenadas respecto a
la base de la imagen bajo la
transformación en tv1
y de dos es simplemente el vector de las
coordenadas respecto a la base de la
imagen bajo la transformación de pedos
de tv2
estos son mis dos columnas así que solo
necesito encontrar cuánto valen estas
dos cosas muy bien entonces cuánto vale
la transformación aplicada a b1 y cuánto
vale la transformación aplicada de dos
pues la transformación aplicada a b1 ya
habíamos visto que simplemente volteaba
este vector hacia el sentido contrario 1
x 1 - y vimos que la transformación
aplicada de uno era menos 21 es decir
era menos de 1
y cuánto vale la transformación aplicada
de dos no escribo aquí en chiquito
la transformación aplicada a b2
recuerden que r2 este vector 12 es
precisamente este vector pues como es un
vector que ya está en la línea su
reflejo es simplemente el mismo las
cosas que están en el espejo no van a
ninguna parte se reflejan en sí mismas
entonces la transformación aplicada de 2
es de 2 nuevamente
de 2 nuevamente muy bien con esto ya
puedo encontrar la matriz de
por qué entonces la matriz de lástima
que no cabe en las dos cosas en la
pantalla
pero la matriz d
pues simplemente son las coordenadas
respecto a la base ve de tv1 la
transformación aplicada de uno pero ya
vimos que eso es menos de uno
en coordenadas respecto a la base be y
la transformación aplicada a b2 vimos
que era simplemente v2 de nuevo
la transformación no le hacía nada a
pedos
así que ahora solo necesito encontrar
cuánto valen estas coordenadas
pero bien
b1 b1 se puede expresar como la
combinación lineal
- 1 por b 1
+ 0 veces 2
así que las coordenadas respecto a la
base de menos de 1
son sencillamente
- 1
y las coordenadas de v2 ya las teníamos
aquí eran 0 1
así que esta es nuestra matriz de
esta es la matriz de menos 100 1
bien ahora como encuentro a partir de
esto la matriz porque recuerden que lo
que yo estoy buscando es la matriz y la
matriz que representa t en coordenadas a
estándar
pues sencillamente
sencillamente
tengo esta fórmula
tengo la fórmula a es igual a la matriz
de cambio de base por la matriz de por
la inversa de la matriz de cambio base
así que ahora necesito la matriz de
cambio de base y su inversa ahora bien
la matriz de cambio de base es la matriz
cuyas columnas son los vectores de mi
base la matriz cuyas columnas son b1 y
b2
así que
la matriz de cambio de base
es sencillamente la matriz 2 - 1
y quién es su inversa quienes sea la
menos uno
pues sea lo menos uno pues sea lo menos
uno es igual a debemos calcular las
inversas de matrices de dos por dos
en numerosas ocasiones es sencillamente
uno entre el determinante de c que sería
2 por 2 que es 4 - menos uno por uno que
es menos uno sí que es cuatro más uno
porque este menos se cancela con el 2 el
otro menos cuatro más uno que es
multiplicada por la matriz en la que
intercambió los elementos de la diagonal
y les cambio de signo a estos dos
- 1
y esa es la inversa de mi matriz de
cambio de base para mí en la fórmula
para la matriz
me dice que es igual hace por deporte al
menos uno
ahora tengo que hacer
es igual a ser
por de force' a la menos 1
es decir
vamos a usar los colores
a es igual al producto de matrices de la
matriz 2 1
- 12
con la matriz d
precisamente la matriz menos 100
y multiplicado por la inversa de la
matriz de cambio base es decir por la
matriz que es igual a un quinto
la matriz 2 - 1 1 2
ok cuánto me da esto primero voy a
trabajar con
usar un color más alegre en el amarillo
vamos a hacer este producto de las dos
primeras matrices
como son matrices de 2 por 2 me da una
matriz de 2 x 2
ahora bien la entrada 11 es el producto
de la primera fila con la primera
columna así que 2 x menos uno que es
menos dos más uno por cero simplemente
es menos 2
la entrada 12 es primera fila con
segunda columna 2 por 0 más uno por uno
la entrada 21 sería menos 1 x menos uno
que es uno más dos por cero de nuevo
aquí tengo un 1
y la entrada 22 sería menos uno por cero
más dos por uno
y ahora esto lo multiplicó por la matriz
voy a poner en un quinto al principio
porque no pasa nada como es el número
real
multiplicar esto por la matriz 211
y cuánto es esto
esto es un quinto por la matriz de
nuestra matriz de 2 x 2 - 2 por 2 es
menos cuatro más uno por uno es menos
cuatro más uno sería menos tres menos
tres luego la entrada 12 sería menos 2
por menos uno que es 2 positivos más 1
por 2 2 más 2 sea 4
1 x 2 2 y 2 puntos 2 2 y 2 hombres de
nuevo 4
y finalmente uno por menos uno es menos
uno más dos por 234 menos uno y cuatro
son tres positivos
así que la matriz
es sencillamente la matriz
tres quintos
los tres quintos
cuatro quintos
tres quintos
esa es mi matriz
bien así que esto fue algo interesante
pude utilizar una base alternativa de r2
la base be conformada por estos vectores
donde la matriz que representaban la
transformación que era la reflexión con
respecto a la línea l tenía una forma
muchísimo más sencilla donde encontrar
la matriz de fue algo más fácil y luego
utilizando la matriz de cambio de base
pude encontrar la matriz que representa
la transformación t en coordenadas
estándar es decir encontré de y a partir
de encontré la matriz a que hacía
precisamente esto así que esta es una
aplicación bonita de las matrices de
cambio base y de las bases alternativas
de rn